كان يقدر ضحاياه ويسرقهم ثم يقتلهم تجول
في بلدان عده بجوازات سفر مزوره صنفه
الانتربول كواحد من اخطر المطلوبين عالميا
الاسم شارل صبرا
قتل نحو 20 شخصا
الافعى
هكذا وصف السفاح صبرا لقدرته على التخفي
عن السلطات كان يقيم صداقات مع ضحاياه
يخدرهم يسرقهم يقتلهم ثم يستولي على
جوازات سفرهم ويتنقلوا بها ولد هذا القاتل
المتسلسل عام
كان عديم الجنسيه في البدايه وبعد انفصال
والديه انتقل الى فرنسا بصحبه والدته وحصل
على الجنسيه هناك
مراهقته ففي التاسعه عشر من عمره دخل
السجن للمره الاولى بتهمه السطوح لكنه
تلقى افراجا مشروطا وبعدها بدات مع عليمه
الاجراميه تكتمل وصناعه ثروه كبيره من
خلال العديد من عمليات السرقه والخداع وتم
اعتقاله من جديد لكنه هرب من السجن عن
طريق تخدير حراسه
سوبراجعد الى اسيا عام 1970 بوثائق مزوره
واستقر به الحال في الهند حيث اعتقل بعد
محاوله فاشله للسطو على محل للمجوهرات
لكنه هرب من السجن الى كابول عبر تخدير
حراسه ايضا وخلال هذه الفتره بدا بالتعرف
على السياح استدرجهم وسممهم واستولى على
متعلقاتهم تنقل سوبراج لاحقا بين تركيا
واليونان وتايلاند وماليزيا ثم القي القبض
عليه خيرا في الهند
بوشيه من شركائه وحكم عليه بالسجن 20 سنه
امضى منها 10 سنوات خلف القضبان ليهرب
مجددا بطريقته المعهوده
عام 1997
عدسه ابراج الى فرنسا وعاش حياه الاثرياء
هناك بفضل الاموال التي دفعت له مقابل
اجراء مقابلات مع صحفيين وفي عام 2003
غادر الى نيبال حيث انتقل هناك وحكم عليه
بالسجن مدى الحياه بتهمه القتل
القضبان لم تمنحه من الاستمتاع بحياته
العاطفيه ففي عام 2008 اعلن عن زواجه من
سيده باليه وهي التي دافعت عنه ضد التهم
التي اعتبرتها ملفقه
اسبوع
في يوليو عام 2010 ايدت المحكمه العليا في
نيبال الحكم عليه بالسجن مدى الحياه
[موسيقى]
الى فرنسا
امين
صرح بانه سيقاضي كثيرين قائلا ان وصفه
بالسفاح وصف خاطئ تماما